if you were gonna sit down another um
actor who maybe was on a path to do
something else
and their parents they were gonna go
meet their parents that weekend and have
that
quote unquote talk yeah what would you
tell them what would be your advice to
that person
you live once and you don't have that
much time on this earth
if there's something you really want to
do i mean you really want to do like
there's nothing else you can do except
for this and it makes you that happy you
have to do it
and and i think that's important for you
know i think there's a lot of people who
are unhappy in this world because
they're doing things they don't like to
do
and yes they're probably financially
secure but they might be miserable
is that really how you want to live the
rest of your life i don't know
for me i i couldn't do that i'm too much
i'm too stubborn for that
so that would be part of the talk if you
were going to advise jack or jill
you know blossoming artist yeah would
that be part of it to like sit mom and
dad down
yeah i i just think you have to be
honest um with yourself and with them
tell them what you want to do now i want
to do this on my own i took the hard
route i didn't ask for anything
i didn't say you know can you finance my
apartment can you
pay for acting classes can you pay for
this i didn't ask for any of that
because because i wanted to be on me
this is my choice i'm leaving
a lucrative career in dentistry or or
medicine
where you know i did get a degree in
biology you raised me
to to be a doctor to be a professional
and i chose a different route
but i won't ask you for anything i'll do
it on my own
you know it that's i think it's easier
for me to do that
than to say i'm gonna i'm gonna choose
this career in acting and to be an
artist
but you can you pay for it that's
a harder conversation but i think i kind
of put pressure on them
because i wasn't asking them for
anything so it wasn't manipulative
but it was like this is my choice i love
you and you're my parents but
i'm gonna do something different than
what you're doing but that's okay
i still love you and you love me and
we're and you're still gonna be my
parents and
i'm still going to support you and
you're still going to support me but
this is what i want to do let's see what
happens
you know and it's been fine they
absolutely love it now and they support
me and they're like my biggest fans
my only fans sounds like you followed up
though with
action absolutely probably the key well
yeah
i went to new york and i was like all
right acting let's go learn how to act
so
i went to terry schreiber i took classes
at cherry trevor studio for years
i got into every class i could i started
signing up for student projects then
independent projects and then i got an
agent and a manager and
you know here i am today do you put a
lot of pressure on yourself to make
things happen
it sounds like you're probably a doer i
get that you have to
there's too many actors in this business
too many good actors in this business
too many bad actors in this business
to not do your best every day i try and
do something there's not an audition
or an opportunity coming up what can i
do to better my career whether it's
updating a website whether it's taking
another class whether it's go work on a
scene
something to do that's creative that
will help me
because you have to be constantly
getting better you're not getting better
you're getting worse
right it's like i was a big a big soccer
player
in college and in high school
and my philosophy was you're only as
good as your last game
you're only as good as your last
practice right athlete's mentality
so for acting you're only as good as
your last audition or your last
you know film you could have an amazing
movie but let's say you do another
film or tv show where the it bombs and
and you know you're not getting good
reaction or good traction
guess what that's the last impression
you're leaving with people so you got to
bounce back
you know so you have to be constantly
getting better my goal is to try and be
doing something every single day
creatively
it's hard that's the hardest thing about
acting is that the jobs there's not an
audition every day you're not going to
work every day steadily until you're at
that level
so what do you want to write you want to
try and do your own
own projects that's the that's the goal
for me
you